This kit is compatible with 2020 to 2026
Honda CRV hybrid.
Hello everyone. Today we'll go over the
step-by-step instructions to add an
additional key using this pro key box
kit. You must have one working key to
add any additional key. This kit is
compatible with many Honda models. I
will add compatibility list at the end
of this video. This kit comes with the
aftermarket key, the programmer tool,
and the instruction manual. If you have
your own unprogrammed key, you can
purchase the programmer separately. This
tool will work on original or
aftermarket key. Today, we'll program
the aftermarket key with the kit. Once
you use this programmer tool, it will
lock to your car vin. This means you can
reuse it many times in your vehicle, but
you cannot use it in any other vehicle.
So, to begin the process, you need to
connect the tool to the OBD board.
Once you connect it, take the new
unprogrammed key out of the vehicle and
only keep the programmed working key in
the vehicle.
Turn the ignition on, but do not start
the car.
From there, press button B and wait for
the blue light.
[Music]
Then take the working key out of the
vehicle and wait for the yellow light.
Once the yellow is blinking, bring in
the new unprogrammed key into the
vehicle and wait for the red and blue
lights to blink.
[Music]
Once the red and blue are blinking, turn
the ignition off.
Then turn it back on.
We will repeat this three more times.
[Music]
At the fourth time, you will hear the
tool long beep indicating the
programming is successful. And now it's
all done. Your key is ready to go. You
can test your key by starting the
vehicle.
As you can see here, it's working. Hope
you enjoyed the video. Thank you for
watching.